ce soir-là aubin il n'y avait pas robert
de niro il était venu le samedi d'avant
ni mick jagger ce sera la semaine
prochaine mais le président de
l'assemblée nationale jacques chaban
delmas
les femmes les enfants
85 kg vont s'y glisser c'est possible
mais il faut garder le silence
non non non soir président à comment on
va une qu'elle surgit
bienvenue parmi nous merci d'être là
pour la première de bain de minuit j'ai
pensé que répondre à votre invitation
était une sorte d'obligation à la fois
sentimentale morale artistes et merci
quand les sucs avait celui ci et
quelques j'ai pensé qu' évidemment je
ferai un peuple à côté d'eux n'est
qu'après tout comme disait libération
nos relances arié libération a dit que
c'était plus forte madonna ne suivez mon
regard
vous êtes venu comme mon président je
suis arrivé en avion de bordeaux tout à
l'air vous êtes venu avec le glam non
oui vous avez un avion du glam
oui oui j'ai eu en avion du glam d'heure
sans ça c'était pas possible et puis
après on est parvenu à pied on est venus
en voiture tout bêtement
malgré la prise d'otage avait pu passer
j'ai des parents ce coup là un bon
d'accord les panneaux solaires de temps
en temps en boîte
non non pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout parce que j'ai
une vie réglée comme papier à musique
le matin alain au petit déjeuner on
m'apporte ma feuille de route et pendant
neuf heures 10h 11h 12h jamais plus de
16 heures mais entre 9 et 16 heures j'ai
un emploi du temps minuté minutes est
minuté minutes et des jeux vous même
faire un aveu pour aller me laver les
mains disons contre le mur on risque
venir au descendant le militaire eh ben
je suis obligé de gratter sur mes rendez
vous lorsque mon horaire est telle qu'on
n'a pas prévu ça et ma vie est ainsi
depuis 40 ans moyennant quoi je me porte
bien jamais pressé j'ai tout mon temps
mais il faut vivre à la minute
alors vous avez quand même des moments
de détente à laurent mérer le bonheur
micheline guilbeault d'air alors si
d'être venu vous aussi parce que dans
l'émission nous voulons toujours
recevoir les gens comme lorsqu'ils
sortent dans l'est dans les boîtes ou
dans les restaurants c'est à dire en
couple ça ne fait vraiment bizarre on
jamais mais ça continue à te demander
quand vous sortez cet ensemble toujours
justement une question qui nous brûle
les lèvres si vous êtes toujours très
amoureux chaque fois qu'on vous voit
dans des photos dans paris match en jour
de france où vous donnez toujours la
main est ce que c'est pour les
photographes ou est-ce que c'est sérieux
c'est instinctif c'est instagram
c'est un réflexe cinéma naturel regardez
là non mais regardez là regardez comme
elle est faite comme en volume je ne
sois pas amoureux de cette fille là vous
allez avoir du mal ce soir proposée est
alors j'essaie alors j'ai cédé j'essaie
d'être persuasif le relais et quand
j'arrive à être persuasif alors j'ai un
petit retour on voit ce que je voudrais
maintenant je sais qu'on est dans une
boîte
j'aurais quand même que vous je crois
que c'est formidable s'est abaissé la
meilleure de paris ça c'est sûr j'ai
découvert ça tout à l'heure mais avec
ravissement
c'est la meilleure fiac c'est du très
bon enfin bon goût c'est très bien
organisé
et puis julien clerc me dit que c'était
pas du tout drogue maquereautage et
compagnie que c'était au contraire tout
à fait vous avez les renseignements
généraux vous en donner de bons
renseignements appelez vous savez que
les renseignements généraux ce soir on
fait passer une fiche entre l'avion la
voiture est ici sur les bains attention
il paraît que c'est un teaser va être là
ce soir je suis le président attention
alors j'en ai fido oui on n'a pas hésité
une grande fête ici aux bains douches
chez qui j'avais si j'avais l'occasion
de faire une grande fête la fac n'est
pas ce n'est pas du tout dit long sur
mon parcours
raison de plus pour être passionné par
ce que je vois ce soir enchantée je
regarde de tous mes yeux je m'informe je
me documente me retenir des regards des
visages des silhouettes superbe risque
colosse et veut dire voilà des gens qui
passent leur ennui comme ça agréablement
moi je passe mes journées à travailler
très agréablement aussi ai adoré ma
femme
en conséquence ce sont des vies
différentes nous sommes d'espèces
différentes
mais cessons les espèces différentes qui
font les peuples et grands peuvent
presque je veux dire président est ce
que je peux vous demander quelque chose
un tout petit peu plus sérieux à parce
que nous avons beaucoup de
téléspectateurs encore plus sérieux
c'est encore de sérieux ce que je dis
même si je le dit en rigolant vous
relirez le texte ça veut dire quelque
chose
d'accord un modeste même pas un modèle
alors le 16 septembre
c'est l'anniversaire de votre discours
sur la nouvelle société c'était quand
même un événement
écoutez il ya trois jours ses excès gré
vous parliez de ça il ya trois jours
j'ai relu attentivement ce discours et
j'ai découvert que sur les 47 pages à
peu près de ce discours était le
discours du premier ministre proposant
la nouvelle société à la france donc une
société
plus responsable plus juste et plus
humaine en résumé j'ai constaté que plus
de 33 34 pages étaient encore d'une
actualité complètement oui et que je
pourrait demain venir lire le discours
est envisagée à lever 33 passe sans que
personne ne moufte
mais c'est vrai que ça fait oublier de
le montrer au président pompidou avant
de le lire à la souveraine c'est vrai
c'est un peu une gaffe ça quand même
bruit oui oui mais c'était une gaffe je
dirais de de bonne foi parce que j'ai
été dressé à la guerre dans le sport
j'ai été dressés à faire équipe et a
joué pour l'équipe et être
extraordinairement pour le patron pour
le chef pour le capitaine pour le
président orwell et ils ne venaient pas
une seconde à l'esprit de pouvoir ni le
trahir ni même pu causer le moins
d'auteurs et comme on l'était sur
discours très pris par les discours j'ai
commis l'erreur de ne pas vérifier au
moins qu'on l'avait envoyé d'accord et
alors vers une heure de l'après midi il
ya eu un coup de téléphone de l'elysée
disant à mon cabinet des points à
l'oeuvre pour younis fait un discours à
4 heures frédéric on préférerait ne pas
le connaître par la presse alors on
s'est précipité en avril et des motards
si on avait pu en vrille et à
l'hélicoptère ont leurs effets mais se
donne évidemment c'était un peu tard
mais entre nous qui avait pas eu à côté
de pompidou des gens pour mettre de
l'huile sur le feu ça n'aurait pas eu
d'effet vous êtes quand même le seul
gaulliste qui a comprimé 68 finalement
non est-ce que vous pensez que si vous
étiez resté aux affaires 4 les
soubresauts de 80 aurait pu être évité
ça je ne sais pas je ne sais pas et je
ne veux pas m'accorder des vertus que je
ne me reconnais pas moi même alors
prévenant sont 114 vouliez devenir
président la république en 86 vous étiez
prêt à devenir premier ministre
oui alors vous auriez fait mieux que
vela giscard espace mieux que jacques
chirac je n'en sais rien j'aurais fait
différemment
bon j'aurais fait différemment c'est à
dire beau serge avait proposé à la
france et aux français un grand dessein
voilà et je crois pas qu'on puisse se
passer d'un grand dessein si on veut
l'en relevé le regard des français
relance et l'espérance est réellement
que ce pays se hisse au dessus de lui
même or c'est nécessaire pour ce pays et
j'espère que le prochain président de la
république quel qu'il soit aura
conscience de cette nécessité d'un grand
dessein et qu'il aura lui le dessin par
exemple d'une nouvelle nouvelle société
car tout reste à faire et je pense que
c'est la bonne voie alors moi je ne suis
pas candidat cette fois ci parce que
comme l'avait prévu le général de gaulle
c'est plutôt trop plein je laisse passer
matin
je laisse passer un tout faire vous
allez faire la campagne de jacques
chirac comme un rat - au premier tour je
puis ré certainement jacques chirac je
suis membre du rpr il est président du
rpr et vous savez dans la vie il faut
toujours jouer
loyal 1 mais quand vous dites on dit
toujours que enfin vous dites que vous
êtes sous-employés un chat bon bien
employer ce serait quoi finalement
au mans j'ai toujours pensé qu'en
réalité non meilleur emploi c'était la
présidence de la république parce que je
crois que ça nous laisse passer en cas
de ma vie je passais ce jour là est ce
que vous connaissez la cicciolina
président eh bien j'en ai aperçu une
photographie une fois il paraît que
c'est une jolie personne elle est très
jolie
j'allais le l'interviewer as roma et
vous en êtes revenu et j'en suis revenu
à peu près à peu près sain et on va vous
montrer sur notre moniteur et passionné
sial on va vous montrer leur port
d'attaché la chézine teach all-in avec
les accents c'est une
titre line collison les personnalités
célèbres y connait qualia mais reste
effaré la mort de mitterrand titre lino
mis trend micro atx et martin petit lino
socialiste
chirac non constitutives d'un chirac ne
lui paraît pas devoir encore que nos
chers la rue ganne non corrigan
l'appareil la moelle golijov gagne pas
toutes à sympatico un acquis sa fosse
commune non comme comme elin a captivé 1
à comines graphie gueddafi et un colonel
et contrit colonel pinochet j'arrive qui
si le fallait car que telle quelle la
personne est l'honnêteté d'audrey et
s'écoule à monthey à qui s'adresse au
tueur au passage du sort d'hitler
non là où tu sais ton nom c'est une
guerre nolasco la force et c'est le
souligne jean à elisabeth la segunda b
non non nous le sommes qui ça c'est la
mano l'amour est alors assez celi piatti
à la nature à la mollesse et lady di non
piquée
dalc'het et jack ou pato constitue
l'hymne marit stefania 10 monaco
stefania motos modernes moto l'idée
qu'il n'y pas d'assez d'ici caroline de
monaco
caroline à son encontre au delà la
famille moreau si l'audience tout un
intitulé no daichi deutsch et 37
berlusconi berlusconi marcello royaume
bnrm aimait et tous et ce tout en un de
ces matins il nous guérit tous les dix
colite si la démocratie quoi les
probablement que tous nos seuils ou
natale padel cap adjibi macky sall c'est
une sonnerie n'est fait et va nous tenir
à l'appel déstabilisèrent dello stato
italien qui sans quoi les probablement
que tout ne se rendent ce soir
tales of est solide elle colle éprouva a
bien mieux tourner cei kweeper procureur
et laïte à tout et l'italienne et b&you
dit koke veste qu'elle ait n'assistait
fatiha moitié tout éclater ces menaces
très redoutée anna lieberman tête sur
you the teacher libère toi midget super
gai ou non sommes nous dans soulac roig
et que probablement que toulouse seysses
à tana sans nous catholiques à qui à
celui dont la bia
qu'est ce que la bd
non le cern tout le sel non non personne
ne sait comment se faire fesser
nationale sont des formations à ses
activistes horizons à malone par lauryn
hill soit maladie soit malade et d
comment ceux qui aiment les connais mal
d'annoncés en annonçant que novice
d'apéro posséder la coloriste une
télévision et sur certaines portions
ok c est la comtesse askar deçà kerala
membres de l'union lyonnais en protéines
si ce qui a poussé par la gioconda six
essais à quoi à kuan à quoi les états
wagner et divine et sordo non et wagner
et beethoven et beethoven coeur si
berlin sinon à quoi les étals a fait
mine de serpenter à la tannerie leurs
prix qu'on lui donne et nous attendons
nous à l'abri vadim and when you're in
asie 6 en une vaste gamme apple s'était
mis en colère et ancien hockey
gwendoline assister à nos une base
solide il taira sous commande de rudolf
hess n'est pas dit qu'ils en 1912 siders
ainsi trop bas la repubblica
démocratique à lucile derrière mais pas
le cas des cds inc
qui est inscrit dans la bière mais selon
ayoubi story soit mal au départ leur ai
mis six ans pour qui ce matin pour faire
de la télévision nbc et la constance à
ce cas quel à la menthe
il en a vu d'alger qui a causé par la
joconde est de 10,6 à quoi les états
wagner divinatoires don maloney la ville
et maintenir la bmd sinon à quoi la vie
et à la féminité reparti à l'attaqué ils
ont alors piccoli voilà alors je voulais
vous montrer ce reportage donne à tous
les trois c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit donc cette fille qui finalement
était la fille d'un
d'un employé du ministère de l'intérieur
à budapest qui est passé très rapidement
en italie à travers un mariage blanc et
qui finalement participe pour enfin -
pour moi à une entreprise de
déstabilisation en attaquant la famille
en prêchant le désarmement en disant
qu'elle préfère faire l'amour avec
gorbatchev qu'avec reagan avec ja rule
explique avec pinochet et je pense et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé à edouard limonov d'être là
parce que c'est edward est un russe
il a vécu aux états unis et maintenant
il vit en france où d'ailleurs il a
beaucoup de mal à avoir un passeport
j'espère que cette émission les draps et
on l'a aussi accusé lui d'être il a eu
des ennuis avec le kgb il est désormais
avec le fbi avec la dst
je voudrais avoir avant qu'on parle de
ceux de sahel sur la voir quand ton avis
sur la question est ce que tu penses
qu'il ya 20 ans kremlin dans un bureau
gris comme ça il ya des types qu'on dit
on va faire élire une prostituée députés
pour ridiculiser la démocratie ou est-ce
que ces paranoïaques de penser ça ils
sont pas aussi visage je crois tu crois
pas qu'ils sont sains
il faut avoir l'esprit des très fute
bizarre peut-être peut-être lesquels
j'ai bel des combats y a plus le livre
dans cet de merde mais je crois pas que
cette bi bien organisé nous avons moi
aussi je suis fils de d'une employée d
merci c'est que j'ai fait dans les
loyers du ministère l'intérieur
soviétique oui on est d'accord mais
c'est une logique plutôt être enfin
finir ajoute genre de choses nous avons
tout de même vu des expériences précise
pas du côté des soviétiques
mais du côté des nazis et est en fait
des anglais car j'ai connu un officier
supérieur de la wehrmacht c'était dans
l'entourage de choltitz et que j'ai
retrouvé un mois et demi a peur de
fichiers anglais il avait passé sa vie
en allemagne sur or il avait gravi tous
les échelons de la hiérarchie militaire
et il ne se démasquer qu'une fois la
guerre terminée c'était du travail
préparé 25 ans à l'avance 30 ans à l'as
vence et il n'était pas le seul
ça fait partie du jeu des services
secrets quand ils sont vraiment solide
bien organisée c'est un jeu normal
évidemment ça surprend elle prêche pour
le désarmement elle prêche contre la
famille soit aussi bientôt tu n'auras
jamais ton passeport
non non pour comprendre le phénomène il
faut les mettre dans les contextes
propres et pour moi et elle est une des
stars de cette consolation formidable
des exilés des pays de l'est parmi qui
vous pouvez trouver les polanski
cergy kosinski écrit banques américaines
maintenant la nina guinée est bon mais
pour devenir les pornostars il faudra
voir les talents oui il faut dire c'est
une ceinture moi j'ai passé une journée
avec elle je veux dire qu'elle est très
les traits et c'est une star en italie
elle passe dans la rue tout le monde lui
dit bonjour on l'appelle on aura volé
parce que c'est honorable quand on est
député
est ce que vous croyez président que en
france les défis comme sylvia bourdon ou
brigitte lahaie pourrait avoir quelque
chance de se faire élire au parlement la
chambre des députés
ça dépend du mode de scrutin s'ils
figurent sur une liste à la
proportionnelle
tout peut arriver tout peut arriver si
une formation politique la place en
situation telle que tout peut arriver
c'est ce qui est arrivé d'ailleurs avec
le pen avec les ti avec celsius et si
c'est eux ajouta uninominal comme mon
desire à l'élection une élection libre
individuel
oui c'est pareil elle n'a aucune chance
n'a aucune chance certains après-midi a
pas beaucoup de monde quand même dans
l'hémicycle on sait qu'ils ont des
petits bureau 101 rue de l'université
est ce que quand il n'y a pas des 5 à 7
un peu je crois un peu non non non vous
voyez pas un chat je crois pas alors
avant de avant de passer à l'interview
jagger je voudrais rappeler les titres
des ouvrages de monsieur limonov il ya
le
le poète préfère les grands [ __ ] mais
c'est très bien je les retrouve sa forme
après cela les femmes je passe les
femmes c'était dernier
oui j'ai déjà publié six livres ici six
livres
oui vous êtes toujours pas naturaliser
français n'ont maintenant je suis là ça
y est ah ben ça s'arrose à moi il va
s'en passer à la fonde et moi je lui
avais très bien décorée
j'ai très bien à la fin juillet mais
très bien bienvenue par 1000 m
je voudrais ajouter un communiqué de
cette valeur là oui pour la france
oui c'est indiscutablement un plus c'est
justement merci madame chaban-delmas
vous vous vous connaissiez limonov
j'en avais entendu parler j'avais vu lu
des articles sur lui mais je n'ai pas
encore lu de livre ou si vous venez
faire un livre là dernièrement dans ac
toute une équipe une équipe alors c'est
un livre de prévention en fait contre la
drogue pour les enfants de 8 à 12 ans
avant parce que déjà les enfants de 8 à
12 ans il faut déjà les c'est surtout
que déjà il faut que très vite un enfant
centre
il est responsable de sa vie qu'il est
chargé de mission vis-à-vis de lui-même
et qu' il y a des choses dans sa vie
qu'il peut choisir ou ne pas choisir
vouloir ne pas vouloir trop mais c'est
de l'art mais on peut le trouver au
partout parce qu'il est distribuée et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus